huh  great you're here did you have a good  read-through of the gliding  sounds like it was a real drag ugh the  gliding manual is super dry  i couldn't get into it really hmm  prime cool stories some of them i like  my favorite one is about the apparently  if you pop an animal slime and take off  in the burst of wind it shoots you up  really really high no not that story  uh what let me take a look  oh shoot oops sorry i put bulk how in  the heck do you compete uh  it's because maybe deep down and what  you lacked was not wind  reading that uh but don't finger okay  then  you just need to follow the marked route  yes  [Music]  yes  you gotta [ __ ] if  you nailed it but if the next part of  the exam isn't  [Music]  all righty then you heard her back to  the city let's not keep her waiting